it's the newest ad popping up around Las
Vegas with a bold statement and catching
attention I think the billboard thing
it's it's a good idea to start with
um but it like the people are so busy in
the streets Billboards aren't like the
most effective uh advertisement like
maybe like social medias the ad can be
seen across four Billboards in high
traffic areas including Warm Springs
Charleston and Las Vegas Boulevard which
is what Archie got its men with a
non-profit organization Juba long was
aiming for so what do you want me to do
half the time I would say nothing I just
don't want you to hate Jews God has been
says high profile incidents in Las Vegas
sparked the movement and now wants to
remind the community about religious
tolerance and rejecting hate
anti-Semitism as an example has
increased
64 percent in Nevada from 2020 to 2021
that is huge and many people aren't even
aware about it but we're changing that
with the Billboards according to the
international Holocaust remembrance
Alliance anti-Semitism is a certain
perception of Jews which may be
expressed as hatred towards Jews both
locals and tourists tell us the
Billboards are great to keep the
conversation flowing I have seen a lot
of like hey hey uh towards any religions
that's um minority I think the billboard
thing it's it's a good idea to start
with
well the nonprofit tells us the
Billboards will be up for the next four
weeks